Hola Raúl muy buenos días os voy a
comenzar con la cifra del día y son los
menos nueve grados que estamos
experimentando aquí en la ciudad alpina
de davos hoy para el inicio de esta
conferencia
por primera vez regresa al invierno
después de que en 2021 fuera cancelada
por la pandemia del covid 19 en 2022 fue
aplazada para el verano debido a la
variante omicron del mismo Coby 19 que
afectó a Europa por ese entonces por
enero del año pasado y pues la agenda de
hoy se limita a una ceremonia inaugural
esta noche por ahora lo que están
haciendo es llegando los invitados de
los diferentes países más de 2700
invitados hay unas estrictas medidas de
seguridad también más de 5.000 efectivos
en el pie de fuerza aquí en davos
desplegados por toda la ciudad desde
luego pero hubo quienes desafiaron esa
despliegue policial para manifestarse el
domingo en contra de este foro económico
mundial diciendo que pues no hace nada
el cambio climático debido a que muchos
de los asistentes diríamos decenas de
los asistentes llegan aquí en sus
respectivos jets privados Dani se nos
acaba el tiempo pero no la quiero
despedir sin hablar de los temas
protagonistas para esta semana
Claro que sí rápidamente el más
importante la recesión que nos amenaza
para este año de hecho hoy se publicó
una encuesta entre los más de 1000
líderes empresariales que asisten a este
foro que en los que en la que dicen que
dos tercios de ellos considera que va a
haber una recesión Durante este año
también rápidamente los jefes de estado
de Estados Unidos y China no van a estar
presentes pero sí van a enviar a sus
delegados y se van a encontrar el
miércoles en la ciudad de